[Music]
foo fighters you gotta get me a record
it's our tenth album we gotta break the
mold on this one
let's go somewhere we've never been
[Music]
this place is amazing
do you guys get this overwhelming sense
of death
doesn't really seem like the right fit
wow that's rad
that was weird the sound of this house
is the sound of album 10.
all right all right you guys amps living
room let me apologize in advance for all
the rock we're about to make
got a couple of ideas i've been working
on i'll lay them on you
dude
it's called everlong and you wrote it
about 20 years ago
how you feeling everything okay ever
since we moved into this house
my mind is flooded
we all have writer's block this is not
just a creepy rock and roll house
it allows spiritual entities to cross
into our world
oh my god
dude has got one flew over the cuckoo's
nest crazy
it's this place man
let's finish the track can we just wait
dude
you found a new musical note oh yes i
did it's an
l
any chefs in the group i'm pretty handy
on the grill
yeah you like your meat charred and dry
he does make a killer barbecue
[Music]
is the album almost done yeah it's
killer
here you go man finish the song
you did
[Music]
you